[Music]
hey everyone I'm ash Carlson and joining
me today some of my faves we've got our
in-house talent danny direct out here
and then our special guest I'm so
excited
star of love Simon Keenan Lonsdale today
we're gonna do is we're just gonna
discuss the movie pit Keaton's brain
talk about everything my name's Simon
I'm just like you except I have one huge
ass secret nobody knows I'm gay
there's there's so many beautiful LGBTQ
stories that have been made and we've
heard a lot about the heartbreak and the
suffering absolutely because it's very
very real and I just think it's
important and it's what I try to express
I guess it's why I wear a lot of colors
but like life is life can be really like
incredible and when you are yourself you
wouldn't have to waste all that time
like trying to be something else like
that's something worth celebrating and
like for me I don't where the movie
isn't just bubbly and happy because
everything's great and groovy it's like
it's a celebration because you've been
through that like journey you've been
through those hardships you've been
through all that stuff like you've gone
through enough pain you can smile now
you can breathe you can exhale like they
say so I think that was an important
thing for Greg to have audiences phew
I'm done living in a world where I don't
get to be Who I am
I deserve a great love story when did
you actually shoot this film like a year
ago probably today we were still filming
like 12 oh yeah
so so you wrote this post where you came
out and I think it's May 2017 hmm did
this film like have any impact on that
on your decision to do that yeah it did
because I wasn't actually at to my cast
like the whole of filming until the wrap
party Wow yeah and I like I'd been out
to friends and I was out to like the
cost of Flash and everything but I just
I always had this thing wherever I met
new people I was like suddenly like went
back into the closet like it always felt
like such a big deal to have to reveal
this thing
and and I realize like I didn't say it
on the first day that I met them and
then I'd made such good friends with him
I felt like I was like lying to them so
then I just was so disappointed in
myself and then one of my friends was
like well don't be disappointed just
like recognized that hey isn't it
interesting that you're you're filming
this movie about a gay love story where
everyone is supportive the director is
gay he has his family with him
everyone's here it's a loving
environment and you're still not
comfortable like what is it that you
have to figure out and so and I told the
cost like on rap night and it was
awesome it was chill it was like no it
was no big deal of course and and then I
think I just started to just reflect
which I had obviously done for a while
but it just it was it was sort of a
final push it made me realize that I was
the only one in control of like how I
saw myself and the fear that I took with
me when I walked into a new situation or
a new job and it just like I felt like
the characters were progressing more
than I was right
you know and so I felt like a bit of a
fraud I'm so used to living other
people's lives as an actor you know so
you know it's like you're your multiple
identities yeah in a lot of ways yeah
kinda hard to confront your own 107 I
think you spend I I would get like
pretty frustrated because like you spend
so much time when these other characters
and after a while you like I don't spend
any time on me I don't know how I dress
I don't know how I like talk I don't
know how I you know I don't even speak
in my normal accent you know so it's
just like after a while I started to
really like I guess almost forced myself
to be myself
which then resulted in me like starting
to really like that guy that I was and
then yeah then I just felt like really
excited I guess and I've been about the
idea of just being me for good I'm
curious how liberating was that for you
when you finally like sent that post out
into the world it was so weird because
as much as I'd been thinking about it
for so long like when I wrote the PO I
didn't know I was gonna write a post and
like put it online
so I actually wrote it in five minutes
and I'd like to am most I don't know and
then pick the picture and like so we
didn't five minutes the whole thing
without it Wow and then it was like I
was a robot like I didn't actually do it
right so then it was out there and I was
like oh I guess that's done like cool
and it wasn't until like my friends and
my publicist called me and they're like
this is awesome just letting you know
what people are gonna ask you about it
and I was like oh I don't want anyone to
ask me about it
like well they might and so that's when
I realized like I had to also come to
terms with the fact that it was gonna be
a topic of discussion and and now I'm so
comfortable talking about it because
like it's it's nothing - I don't know I
let it go so it just feels like very
easy to discuss and thankfully there's
parallels with this movie and your story
yeah it makes sense to kind of share
that there's a lot of we're out there
struggling - that's what I love so much
about this movie like I'd have this this
movie when I was coming out in high
school you know I this is like the game
pretty in Pete the gay never been kissed
I've always wanted you know so a lot of
people gonna watch this movie and what
and follow Simon's story follow your
story and really you know identify with
it yeah I also think like when you're in
the closet like you get used to seeing
all of these love stories that you feel
like they're talking to you cuz yeah
they are it's still about love but then
like once once I saw a lot of Simon and
you actually you know you're it's a love
story about a guy for another guy and it
really hits home in a place that is
really unexpected I think like and
that's why they say representation
matters but it really does like it sits
and I didn't it didn't hit me as much
until I actually saw the film so well
feels like they're talking to me okay
well I want to get more into the
spoilers of the movie so you guys go see
love Simon out March 16th and then we'll
do another video or we'll get into all
the details of the movie cuz there's a
lot of things so come on back thank you
guys so much for watching
[Music]